hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
there's plenty rumors about the next
iphone the iphone 7 or 7 plus or 7 pro
or whatever it's called having two
camera lenses i mean there's plenty of
other rumors about the next iphone but
that's the one we're focusing on also lg
and huawei both in the last year worked
with google to make the next smartphones
that we got and then exactly a year
later now here both companies also have
a dual camera smartphone out on the
market what do they know that we don't
it'll be really interesting to find out
obviously but with vr having a really
big year and 360 degree video having a
really big year and you could argue that
the features in smartphones over the
past couple years have slowed down a
little bit it wouldn't be a huge
surprise to see a bunch of smartphones
in the next one or two years that have
dual cameras on the back so here's the
deal this is one of the smartphones with
the dual cameras on the back this is
what it looks like this is the lg g5
it's also a really interesting phone in
a bunch of other ways full review of it
coming soon but this is what the dual
cameras on the back of a smartphone
looks like and like i said there's a
bunch of others with dual cameras but
here's the thing to note is there's
almost never two identical cameras it's
usually one main camera and then also
another secondary camera and then that
secondary camera captures sort of extra
information or a slightly different
image that's usually given back to add
to the original now one of the ogs at
this whole dual camera in a smartphone
thing was the htc evo 3d back in 2011
and this one actually did have identical
cameras on the back so two of the same
camera the back module was huge and
essentially we used both of those
cameras to take a slightly different
image from that slightly different angle
it would stitch them together in
software to create a 3d image that you
could look at on its glasses-free 3d
display now i wouldn't say this flopped
but it kind of did i mean this was back
in 2011 and how many other 3d
smartphones have you seen since then
exactly so more recently a phone that
came out with dual camera lenses on the
back this one's probably more
recognizable is the htc one m8 so this
one had a main four megapixel camera on
the back and a second sensor
specifically for recording depth
information of the whole scene so with
this it would be able to tell what was
in your photo in the foreground what was
further away in the background and then
you could apply some software effects to
like fake bokeh or whatever artsy stuff
to take advantage of this separation now
again i wouldn't say this one flopped
either in fact the one series is still
part of htc's most important line of
smartphones right now
but this first one was i mean the
software wasn't that it was subpar at
best is what i'm saying uh a lot of
times you couldn't even tell if it was
really even using that depth information
the bokeh would get all glitchy on the
edges and you'd wonder why so it wasn't
fantastic but it was a pretty cool
concept now fast forward to 2016 and we
have smartphones like the lg g5 and the
huawei p9 again like i said from the two
manufacturers that happened to work with
google on a smartphone last year this g5
has a regular 16 megapixel camera on the
back with a regular field of view but
then right next to it next to the laser
autofocus is an additional camera a
super wide angle 135 degree 8 megapixel
camera for those crazy super wide shots
and you can switch between them on the
fly if you want to so they don't really
work together to add information to one
image but it can be pretty fun to play
with this super wide angle kind of looks
almost like a gopro camera a lot of
times so you can get these cool
landscapes or architectures in the city
or whatever other really wide-angle
shots you think look dope and the huawei
p9 is the other one i don't have a p9
with me but the p9 is the same deal
primary camera and secondary the primary
is a regular rgb sensor and the
secondary camera is a monochrome sensor
so it's like a black and white camera
but because it's less color information
it can do additional detail and
sharpness and dynamic range and it'll
take that image information and use
software to stitch it together with the
original rgb image to create a much
better looking original photo so right
now there really isn't any theme or
overlapping standard for why smartphones
have dual cameras on the back it's just
sort of a mix and match do whatever you
want with it so like we said we're
expecting apple to probably have an
iphone 7 or 7 pro or something like that
with maybe two camera lenses on the back
but we don't know what apple would be
doing with that we don't know if it
would be maybe two identical image
sensors doing stereoscopic 3d
or would they be like a primary
secondary type of thing where the
secondary one would pick up additional
color information or light values we
just don't know what we do know is it's
a feature and it's not really quite up
to its full potential right now in
smartphones as we see them mostly
because we don't even know what that
full potential really is
i would like to see
two identical cameras on the back but
facing slightly apart from each other so
that they could capture two simultaneous
high-resolution images and then stitch
them together into one high-res panorama
without software tricks i think that
would be pretty dope or maybe something
else related to vr and we see all these
360 degree videos all the time now on
facebook and on youtube
obviously having a smartphone that can
capture 360 degrees without an extra
accessory that you have to carry around
would be pretty cool but again this is
all just wishful thinking from one
person but what it's cool to know is
that it's not just me thinking about
this stuff it's a lot of people so we
know that there are companies every day
working to try to make this into
something cool so when the next iphone
or the next samsung or the next nexus
comes out and has dual smartphone
cameras
now you know why thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace